- He gets hurt all the time. The main person that always gets
hurt for everything.
[Buzzer]
It's Derrick Rose!
- Hold on, Druski!
I think you know better than anybody I love games.
- Yes.
- So I'll tell everybody: It was me, our mutual friend Jack Harlow—
- And one of Druski's other friends. We played "Heads Up!"
And Jack and I were partners.
We murdered Druski.
- Yeah.
- It wasn't even close.
I started doing that in the NBA bubble.
I would play "Heads Up!" with the guys,
and then everybody would
compete to get the highest score.
- Yeah.
- So we're doing that now on this show.
- OK.
- So you at least wanna get a somewhat respectable
score.
- Ahh!
- [Taylor Rooks:] [Laughing]
Ready?
- I'm ready.
Put it more in the camera now so I can see it.
Uhh, uhh, it's
in Oklahoma. It's a team in Oklahoma.
Umm, college team in Oklahoma. What's the mascot?
- Oklahoma Sooners?
- Uhh, nah, nah, nah...it's—
- Oklahoma State Cowboys?
- OK, no, no. Skip it. Skip it.
Skip it. Skip it.
Skip it! Yo, skip it!
Umm, when you, when you—
it's the opposite of offense.
- Defense?
- Yeah. I need you to respond quicker. Come on.
Goddamn.
- [Laughing]
- Umm, not,
not when you say
Your Highness.
- Your—
- Uh, all right. Put it up. Put it up. Skip it. Skip it.
Um, dang, he
was the, he was the best player that ever played for the 76ers.
- I mean...
- What?
- Allen Iverson?
- Yeah, come on.
Yes. All right, uh.
- [Laughing]
- I can't
explain this one. I can't explain this one.
Go down. Go down. Cuz it, go, yeah, pass it.
[Buzzer]
Uh, he gets hurt all the time. The main person that
always gets hurt for everything.
[Buzzer]
- [Laughing] Hold on. Hold on, Druski. Druski!
- Goddamn it. It's Derrick Rose. How do you not know?
- OK, first I wanna say the Hoosiers are Indiana.
- Oh, OK, my fault. I was way—
- And then, you couldn't get me to say Dr. J?
- Eh, I didn't know what team he played for. I just knew he
was an old hooper.
- You've been able to do some really cool things.
Obviously, one of the many great things was being in the
"Laugh Now Cry Later" music video with Drake,
Lil Durk, KD [Kevin Durant], Odell [Beckham Jr.].
How did that come to fruition?
And were you like, what is happening?
- Yeah, nah, nah. I had already been friends with the
boy for a minute, man.
I think they were looking for somebody to fill a role of, like,
a comedic role for that video. And he
was just letting me know, like, “Yo, I think it would be
perfect, you know what I'm sayin', for the culture if we
come together and make this happen.” And I was like, “Damn, like, yo, of course.”
- Yeah.
- Like, you know what I'm sayin’? I definitely can't let that down.
But, nah, it was fun, though. I ain't gonna lie. It was, it was real fun, man.
- Yeah, and I know obviously you got to do it with Odell—
- Yeah.
- But you and Odell are also—
- Mmhmm.
- Already very good friends.
- Yeah. You know, it's crazy when we were, when we were on the field,
they were recording, we was fooling around the whole time.
- But people don't know: Odell's really funny as well.
All Odell does is goof around.
- [Both laughing]
- And, like, that's literally all that he does.
- Yeah, man. People don't know.
I think, I think I tell O all the time, he has, he has a
bright future in like, in Hollywood, outside of even being
famous for football.
- Tell me the best three phone numbers you have saved.
- Damn.
- [Laughing]
- Not leaking that! Shit!
Ah, between Justin Bieber and Jaden Smith.
I have their numbers.
Justin Bieber, he wanted—he had hit me about being on
Coulda Been Records, this live thing that I do.
- Yes. [Laughing]
- But he had FaceTimed me that same night, and he had like a
whole, like, 30-minute convo with me about, like,
just God and, you know, just like, just life in general.
And just about—
- Yeah.
- Everything, you know, he's been through and giving me a little
bit of, you know, advice on different things, so
he's actually a genuine—I did not expect that.
So when he FaceTimed, I'm going like, “What?”
- Yeah, he's really kind.
- What the what? Yeah, dude, I'm talking about he even started
singing on the phone and I'm like, “Yo, like, what?”
- What'd he sing?
- What, it was some angelic shit, and I don't know what
it was.
- [Laughing]
We're gonna run the basketball category back. OK?
- OK.
- Are you ready? Cuz I think, I think you could do a little better than that.
- You just had to warm up. I think you need to warm up
a little bit.
I think you can do better
- Oh, I was ready.
- I think—OK, it's, uh, man.
It happens when you, you—ahhh! I can't
say the word. All right, skip it.
Your hand. Your hand. What's the thing around your—
- A ring. A glove.
- Oh, my God.
- What?
- Are you, are you nuts?
All right, come on. Skip it.
Um, skip it.
Ahhh, skip it.
- Oh, my God!
- OK, OK. He, he's, he's, he's,
a white hooper, and he played for the Phoenix Suns.
- Um—
- Jesus Christ.
- A wristband?!
A chest pass?!
- OK, yeah.
- Hakeem Olajuwon?!
- All right. Explain to me how I'm gonna say Hakeem Olajuwon.
- A lot of people maybe think, OK, you can turn it on just for the internet.
- Yeah.
- But this is actually how you act—
- 24/7, all the time.
So my question is—
- You sound like you've gotten annoyed
with me once or twice. [Laughing]
- [Laughing]
But my question is like, what's the difference?
You know, like what separates the people that are funny in
real life and the people that are just funny in a specific,
you know, like, area?
- That's a good question. Damn. I think with stand-up comedians,
there's, like, a huge difference, which I'm getting into now.
I think that just creates the longevity of it.
If you can be funny in real life, I think it
takes away the whole, like, persona of
“I'm gonna to be this person when you see me.”
- So have you done stand-up yet?
Or you're working towards doing stand-up?
- I'm actually working on a set right now
that's gonna be premiering soon.
- Really?
- So, yeah.
- How we feeling about it?
- I feel good. I'm still, you know, rubbing out the kinks and
jinks, so, you know.
- Is it easier or harder than you thought?
- Harder, cuz I think sometimes things that you think in your
head might not be as funny when you say it.
- [Laughing] Yeah.
- So, just learning, just learning.
So, as you continue to learn, it's like, OK,
this isn't as easy as I thought.
I'm trying to prove my works can be past, you know,
just social media and, like, passed even—
you know, I work with a lot of, like, different music
people. Like, now I feel like I have bigger goals to
accomplish, like working with people in movies and TV
and like more comedians getting involved with more live
stuff, you know, that you probably been seeing me do, you know.
But, yeah, just, I feel
like I always try to get that next thing.
- I know with your new podcast with Mountain Dew, you'll be
talking about hoops. You'll be talking about culture.
Tell me that intersection that's gonna happen with that
podcast with Mountain Dew.
- We got some, we got some heavy hitters coming on there.
We got Bam, Myles Turner,
my boy Jamal Murray.
Shit, I mean, you may get an appearance on it, so, you know, you
know, you know, you know, you know.
- [Laughing]
- It's so many people in basketball that are just, you know,
talented and can do a lotta other stuff.
So it's good to shed light and to get to know these people
more personally, you know.
- We're gonna switch to your custom decks.
- OK.
- We're gonna see how you do with those.
- OK, OK.
- Let me show you how to do this. Close your eyes.
He's a comedian.
"No, no." That guy. He talks like that.
- Uh, Kevin Hart. Kevin Hart.
- Yes.
Oh, we—our friend. We played "Heads Up!" with him.
Rapper,
Tyler Herro.
- Jack Harlow.
- Yes.
Um, this is where we're from.
We just talked about it.
- Gwinnett County.
- Yep.
This is another rapper.
I don't know how to explain him, though.
OK, so he is in—
OK, the best player in basketball, what's his name?
Blank Jordan
- Ahh, oh, Post Malone.
[Buzzer]
- [Laughing] OK, hold on. No. Skip this one, Rocky.
Skip it. Skip it. Skip it.
- Um, um, um, um.
- No, no, no, no. It's OK, Druski.
- Is it Majid Jordan?
- OK, no, this is another rapper.
He's from Houston. He's, like, he did "Sicko Mode" with Drake.
- Oh, oh, oh, Travis Scott.
Duh.
- Yes, yes.
Oh, this is Kanye's shoes.
What are they called?
- Yeezys.
Yes.
Go, go, go, go, go!
Oh, this is the HBCU in D.C.
- Oh, ah, Howard.
- Yay! [Clapping]
See, now, Druski, that's how you give clues.
- Wooo. All right. All right. You're good. You're good.
- On "Just Playin'" we always end each show by asking the guests
some questions that are rapid fire. So they'll be quick. You give
me the first thing that comes to your mind.
OK?
- Mmhmm.
- Ready?
- Yes.
- All right. Fill in the blank.
Druski is—
- Legendary.
- Ooh, I love it. OK. Biggest "W,"
either career or personal.
- I haven't got there yet. I'll tell you that.
- Worst habit?
- Eating cereal, man. I'm addicted to eating cereal, bruh.
Like, yo, I ain't even gon' lie to you.
- I was gonna say "last meal," but I assume it might be cereal.
- Yeah.
- OK.
If you don't like “blank,” something is wrong with you.
- If you don't like comedy, something's wrong with you.
- OK.
- Seriously, cuz there's people out here that—how do
you not like to laugh?
- Advice to your younger self?
- To just stop caring what everybody thinks about you and just
do, just live in your purpose.
That's one thing I needed to hear when I was, like, 18.
- Yeah, and look at you now—living in your purpose.
- Yeah, man.
- Well, Druski, thank you for coming on "Just Playin’,”
playing some games with me.
We're gonna work on it, but shout-out to you.
- Thank you.
Way to shit on me on the way out, right?
- [Both laughing]
- Nah, I appreciate you, man. It's always good choppin' it up with you, for real.
- Yes, always a pleasure.
- Good people.
- Hopefully see you soon.
- Yes, definitely see you soon.